In today's video,
we're looking at a couple
of DJI products,
the Mavic 2 Zoom and
the DJI smart controller.
With that, we're also going
to be showing you a bit of
what Grant's been up to.
[Music]
Hey guys, for those of you
who don't recognize me,
I'm Mark, the camera guy.
I've been filming
for The King of Random
for almost three years now.
And since I'm the one
who's behind the camera,
you usually don't see my face.
But since DJI sent
us a couple of drones
and the new smart controller,
me and Calli thought I
better get my own opinion.
Now, I've flown
all sorts of drones,
and honestly, DJI is
my favorite brand.
My two favorite drones
are the Mavic Air,
and the Mavic 2 Zoom.
The Mavic Air for its small
lightweight form factor,
and the Mavic 2 Zoom
because it has
the zoom lens on it.
So DJI did give us
these drones for free.
They didn't pay us to say
anything special about it.
They just wanted me
to give an honest opinion
about what I think
about the drones.
They also give us
an extra Mavic 2 Zoom
so we can give that one away.
So if you want
to win this drone,
stick around to the end
of the video,
and we will tell you how.
And let's do a quick unboxing
of the DJI smart controller.
[Music]
All right, sweet.
So here's the controller.
It looks pretty cool.
Oh, I like the heft.
It has a good amount
of weight to it.
I like the flip up antennas
that reveal two joysticks.
That's pretty cool.
[Music]
It has some pretty
standard buttons on here,
similar to what other
DJI controllers have.
That start up has a really
nice bright display.
So that's pretty cool.
[Music]
I will just quickly do
the setup for the controller.
Go into the quick tutorial.
Peeling off some stickers.
Oh sweet, it looks like it has
an HDMI port, SD card slot,
and a USB port.
I wonder what that one is for.
Yeah, I really like
this 5.5 inch display.
And the touch screen
is really nice,
just like any other smartphone.
Okay.
Let's see what else
comes in the box.
It looks like a power cable,
an extra set of joysticks.
Oh, and the pretty
hefty wall wart.
All right, sweet!
Let's take this over
to Nate and Calli,
and show it off.
Hey guys, have you guys seen
the new DJI smart controller?
Sweet.
It's got a 5.5
inch screen built-in.
It's full HD, 1080p.
It has the OcuSync 2.0,
which gives you 8 kilometers
of connection with the Drone.
Holy cow.
It runs Android operating system
so you can like
download third-party apps.
Can I play Angry Birds?
I don't know.
I'm gonna try.
[Music]
I'm very impressed
that you can just play this
on this controller.
That's awesome.
Hey, what do I did?
Do I-- No, I'm helping.
>> I'm--
>> You're not helping.
I'm helping.
>> Not helping.
>> I'm helping.
>> Very unhelpful.
What am I doing?
What am I supposed to be doing?
Ruining things.
Look at that, how I helped.
I ruined?
I fixed it.
So you said that you've already
kind of field tested this,
and you like it, right?
Yeah, I like it a lot.
So we need more footage.
We need to see.
I think we gotta--
Yeah, we got to take this thing
out, and see what it does.
Go.
I want to see.
I wanna see what
this looks like.
Sweet, I'll take it
out to the desert.
Cool.
Hey, you guys want
to come with me?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Yeah, sure.
Okay.
[Music]
Yeehaw!
It's a little bit
frosty out today,
but we made it happen for you.
All right, we got it.
That was cool.
That was amazing.
So, would you recommend
this to everyone?
Probably not everyone.
It's kind of like
a niche market I feel
like for who should buy this.
People probably already know
if they need it or not.
So if you're debating on
whether you should get it,
I say go ahead and get it.
What are-- What are like the top
two reasons you should use that,
instead of the original
controller with your phone?
Because it was beautiful.
The footage that we got
in the desert was phenomenal.
Yeah.
Definitely with that
1000 nit display
on here versus like what,
it's like 700 or 800 nits.
It's a lot brighter.
It's just built in.
You don't have to worry
about having your phone charged
and the controller charged.
You can just charge this,
and be good for two
and a half hours.
Guys, check the link
in the description
for how to enter to win
your very own Mavic 2 Zoom.
This is still sealed in the box.
This is a cool drone.
You can get good footage
of this thing.
It may--
It's the same.
>> It may--
>> It's the same.
It make it shipped out.
It may--
Calli might steal--
We'll make sure to get
it back from her.
Hey guys, thanks for watching.
If you're not a subscriber yet,
hit the bomb to get in the club.
If you missed our last video,
or you want to watch it again,
click up here at the top.
Click down there
if you want to see
what the internet thinks
you should watch next.
That's it for now.
Have fun.
Be safe.
See you tomorrow.